I'm always positive I've had my muesli
I'm ready to go the morning the unions
came to Westminster
from Rail and health we will listen we
will talk and we will negotiate to
education members don't want to go on
strike and we don't want them to go on
strike we want a resolution to this
officials in and out of departments for
talks to avert the biggest wave of
strikes in decades
meanwhile is a health center in Leeds
the Prime Minister not ruling out the
idea of one-off payments for workers
wage packets you wouldn't expect me to
comment on specifics but the most
important thing is that the
conversations are happening that people
are talking and with regard to pay we
have to have those conversations based
on what is Affordable what's reasonable
what's responsible for the country
but after a morning of meetings what's
the block on a deal at the moment
tight lips from rail unions and anger
from ambulance reps all that the
government are interested in is saying
that in order to justify a payment then
we need to find we need to come up with
productivity savings uh in the NHS that
is absolutely uh ludicrous this isn't a
factory we're talking about we are
talking about people who are working
well beyond their contracted hours uh
anyway but other health unions more
optimistic now pay is at least being
discussed we didn't get the tangible
concessions that we might have hoped or
that would enable us to call off the
stripes later this week and and next but
it was definitely a progress we were in
a room with the Secretary of State
talking about pay
today was always unlikely to be a
breakthrough moment but there has been a
shift in tone from the government when
talking about the standoff with unions
and there's been a material change too
with the possibility of one-off payments
rejected just weeks ago by number 10 now
appearing to be on the table
any deal may not come in time to stop
ambulance and nurse strikes later this
month though people in Leeds appearing
supportive of NHS workers the NHS needs
support and their partnership prime
minister is not supporting them at all
never has done given the pay rise give
them everything that they need
everything's going up what the wages
don't go how did the course go this way
no news might be good news but for now
the strikes remain
but at least now everyone's talking
both sides aware of the dangers of a
protracted battle Rod palski news in
Westminster